[Music]
here we go again sony have revealed the
games playstation plus subscribers will
receive for the month of may 2022. you
can download the following games from
tuesday the 3rd of may be sure to leave
your opinion in the comments below as i
know the playstation do read them so
let's crack on on both the ps4 and ps5
is tribes of midgar it calls itself a
co-op survival action rpg which supports
10-player cooperative play we set up our
viking village and are tasked with
protecting the seed of idrisil a big
magic tree every time night falls
creatures from the underworld attack
your village this continues until
ragnarok arrives the end of the world
that tree eats souls by the way and it's
our job to bring them to it in exchange
for new abilities after creating our own
viking we can go it alone or bring in
team mates and work together while
exploring the world we'll gather
materials for crafting items such as
armor potions and even our hometown's
defenses tribes of midgard is
procedurally generated making every area
a new game a completely different
experience oh and i forgot to mention
the best thing giants at random points a
game ending giant will begin marching
towards your home if you've prepared
well enough this is your chance to
defeat a legendary foe and collect its
very rare loot and then do it all over
again the user and critic review say
this is a 7 out of 10 game so will you
try it and more importantly do you have
9 friends to play with next we have fifa
22 on both the ps5 and ps4 whether you
call it football or prefer soccer you do
you fifa received its annual update and
this year it's slower than previous
iterations to try and combat the meta of
finding the fastest players and running
forward this is down to a refined
animation system which forces each
player to use the correct body shape
before releasing the ball a patient
build up and a more considered approach
is rewarded and thanks to that the game
looks more like real life than ever
before if the core of fifa is becoming
simulation then volta is 100
the arcade version if you've ever played
fifa street you'll know the idea smaller
courts smaller teams more flair on the
ball and more aggression too there are
many games to play for quick xp farming
and a break from the more serious parts
of fifa other improvements include
creating your own team designing their
kit and crest and steering them up the
football league buying marquee players
along the way if you've played fifa
before it's definitely more fifa and
it's easily the best football game on
the market but there isn't much
competition if i'm honest what are your
thoughts on receiving a sports game in
ps plus and finally on the ps4 is curse
of the dead gods a top down action
roguelike which has impressive reviews
we journey to a temple and make our way
through its procedurally generated
levels using 10 different weapon types
each weapon and upgrade we find will
offer slightly different stats like
elemental damage health regen or other
slight buffs but this is a roguelike so
if we die we must restart the entire
game luckily there are some permanent
upgrades to unlock on good runs which
give us a step up on our next attempt
curse of the dead gods fighting
mechanics are addicting with a stamina
meter those diamonds underneath our hero
count down and therefore must be managed
and so do the curses we pick up on route
these debuffs can only be cleansed by
defeating a boss the end goal is to
complete the entire game in one single
life and that'll take you around 30
hours i'm told ign say this game is
amazing giving it 9 out of 10. will you
try it what do you think to this month i
think i'm going to jump into tribes of
midgar what are you playing please let
me know in the comments below i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]